mark wagner's volkswagen rolled off the
assembly line back in 1962.
it's definitely my daily driver and if
i'm going uh grocery shopping if i'm
going to hockey
if i'm
running errands like this is this is the
car while most beetles from the kennedy
era have long since made a one-way trip
to the junkyard wagner's runs like a
dream and fast too because this old
beetle is now an electric vehicle it's
clean it's quiet
it's reliable there's a lot less moving
parts and a lot less thing can go wrong
it's a joy to drive more and more owners
of broken down or mechanically
challenged classic cars are taking them
to shops like evie west
where owner mike bream and his expert
crew flipped them from fossil fuel to
electrons we remove the engine
in associated components so the fuel
tank the exhaust system
sometimes the transmission all of these
are replaced with an electric motor and
a tesla battery there seems to be no
shortage of tesla drivers wrecking their
cars and providing a plentiful supply of
parts
cars being retrofitted here include a
classic bmw a sleek black corvette and
even a gull wing delorean ready for a
trip back to the future the cost of an
electric overhaul ranges from eighteen
thousand to thirty thousand dollars
if you want to convert your classic car
to an electric vehicle you're gonna need
some patience
at this shop for example the waiting
list for new customers is five years
so our typical customer is one that
really loves their car either it has a
you know significance to the family
maybe it's been handed down or you know
a customer has driven it since high
school so typically
automotive enthusiasts best describes
our customers right now those customers
are also laughing at sky-high fuel
prices breem says he's concerned about
the environment and global warming but
reducing co2 emissions isn't his big
motivation i'm a motorhead i'm a hot
rodder i'm a speed guy wagner is proud
that his old vw isn't making the climate
crisis worse i'm excited to
take it up to the mountains driving
through the national forest not
polluting anything whether it's for
going green or going for speed classic
cars are getting a new electronic lease
on life
rob reynolds al jazeera san marcos
california